u.s forces are exiting afghanistan after
a 20-year mission that became known
as america's longest war today biden
said the military campaign will end
august 31st
while the u.s will not stay involved in
afghanistan militarily
biden says diplomatic and humanitarian
work
will continue in an effort to protect
the thousands of afghan interpreters and
translators who helped u.s and nato
forces
biden announced that the u.s military
will operate flights throughout august
to evacuate them and their families
they will be taken to an unannounced
safe country as they wait for their
visas
to be approved now the taliban are going
from strength to strength in afghanistan
taking over more
territory and that process has only
accelerated as foreign troops leave
biden's message after 20 years u.s and
nato no longer have a job to do
in afghanistan the future of afghanistan
must be determined by
afghans and that includes in 2021
just as it did in 2001 dealing with the
taliban
here is the u.s president our military
mission afghanistan will conclude
on august 31st the drawdown is
proceeding in a secure and orderly way
prioritizing the safety of our troops as
they depart
our military commanders advised me that
once i made the decision to end the war
we needed to move swiftly to conduct the
main elements of the drawdown
and in this context speed is safety
and thanks to the way in which we have
managed our withdrawal
no one no one us forces or any forces
have uh
have been lost conducting our drawdown
differently would have certainly come
with the
increased risk of safety to our
personnel
that was the u.s president there earlier
i spoke with trida parsi
he's executive vice president at the
quincy institute for responsible
statecraft he is an authority on
geopolitics from iran
to saudi arabia to afghanistan and i
asked him if there is
any positive news in this announcement
given that the taliban
is resurging in afghanistan
i think it's important to recognize that
the taliban was resurging
and would be resurging regardless as to
whether the united states would be
leaving or not after 20 years
we have now people saying that the
afghan government cannot stand
alone for six months well after a
20-year investment and they can only
hold out for six months
what does that tell us it tells us that
another year another two years another
20 years
will not make a difference and that is
bringing the united states to a point in
which it has to decide
does it want to continue to engage in an
endless
unwinnable war or is it going to
withdraw
and recognize that the original
objective of defeating the al-qaeda
there
has been achieved and settle for that
yeah the original objective the mission
of going into afghanistan the president
said today was to rid the country of the
terrorists
who had hit the united states but wasn't
that mission accomplished in 2011
when osama bin laden was killed
i think in general uh had it just been
an objective
to go after the taliban and al-qaeda
there
it would have been achieved much earlier
perhaps even earlier than 2011 mindful
of the fact that
bin laden was killed in pakistan not in
afghanistan
i think this is a typical case of
mission creep
in which we originally went in because
of al-qaeda attacking the united states
and then it dwarfed into a
nation-building project
counter-intelligence a counterinsurgency
and it's just been dragging on
this is part of the reason why the
united states should be extremely
selective
when it comes to using force outside of
its own borders
and be extremely selective when it comes
to uh the type of military interventions
that we're seeing here
because once it is started usually there
are very
very few good options left and you will
be forced to only choose between bad
options i heard one u.s lawmaker today
say that the this war would have turned
out much differently
had there not been the invasion of iraq
two years after the start of the war in
afghanistan and this congressman said
that what happened is you had the u.s
trying to focus on two wars neither of
them got complete
attention and you see that mission creep
began as you just said
um is the failure in afghanistan if you
want to call it that
does it have something to do with iraq
um i'm not so convinced by that because
at the end of the day
even if the united states had not gone
into iraq and clearly going into iraq
did not help
but had it not gone into iraq it would
still have been a very difficult mission
because
nation building in afghanistan is not
what the united states is equipped to do
you can take a look at iraq see how
badly nation building went there
as well the problem is that from the
very beginning the mission actually was
limited to defeating the
al-qaeda and then it morphed into
something much much bigger
had that not happened we would be in a
very different situation today you know
the the first questions for the
president from reporters today
were are you handing over afghanistan to
the taliban
were the past two decades in afghanistan
were they worth it
what would be your answers well i think
the premise of that question is quite
incorrect
handing the afghanistan over to the
taliban
presumes that the united states is in
control of afghanistan the united states
is not in control afghanistan and has
not been in control of afghanistan
that's been the problem from the very
beginning
a lot of folk seems to have the
impression that afghanistan some way
somehow is the 51th state of the united
states
and now the by the administration or
whoever had been trump would be handing
it over to someone else
this was never the united states this
was their country
and the us was never in control of it i
think uh uh
assumptions as such has really made the
conversation in the united states
much more difficult about what type of
irrational choices
it can choose between and moving forward
what what will you tell the
administration what should we expect in
the next year in afghanistan um the
government with with the taliban and of
course there's the role of pakistan
and even the role of china to consider
i think it is essential that when the
military mission is now ended
that the united states remains engaged
diplomatically to try to help stabilize
um afghanistan it's going to be very
challenging but one thing the united
states can and should do
is to encourage the regional states the
neighboring states
to really step up and their incentives
to do so has now
increased as a result of the united
states leaving
for instance if you take a look at what
the iranians have been doing in many
ways the iranians had shared interests
with the united states and afghanistan
and opposed the taliban but as long as
the united states was in afghanistan and
was seen as a threat by the iranians the
iranians did not
collaborate with the united states and
actually in many ways undermined the
united states deliberately
fearing that if they didn't the united
states would have greater bandwidth to
attack iran
with the united states not being present
there this dynamic changes and their
opportunities for collaboration and
diplomacy grows but it takes
initiative leadership and participation
by the united states so i think it's
essential
that just because the troops are back
home does not mean that the diplomatic
mission in any way shape or form should
and in fact it should be ramped up
yeah that is exactly what the president
said earlier today
trader parsi we appreciate your time and
your insights tonight thank you